Vladimir Putin
publicly berated his minister of industry
and trade, for,
he says, acting too slowly
in completing orders
for military and civilian aircraft
contractor Why are you falling around
the ceiling
if you think that it will be ready
during this quarter of the year?
Based on the funds available
under the budget through the budget?
Mr..
I want all of this to be done
within a month.
We will try to do our best and,
you know, do not try to do your best.
Please get it done in a month. No, later.
See Bush
joined now by senior national security
analyst Steve
Hall, a former CIA
chief of Russian operations,
and CNN contributor Jill Dougherty,
a global fellow at the Woodrow
Wilson Center.
Steve, it's interesting
to see Vladimir Putin saying that.
I mean, one,
I would not want to be
on the receiving end of that
from any boss, let alone Vladimir Putin.
But it's also clear
Vladimir Putin wants to be seen
as being tough on
you know, on this bureaucrat.
Yeah,
Anderson, this is obviously nothing,
nothing but show and showmanship.
I mean, Putin has done this before.
He does it
with oligarchs occasionally
where he sort of upgrades
and then downgrades them publicly.
There's, of course, any number of ways
that Putin could have done
this privately,
which would be sort of more
in the Western tradition
where you sit down,
you know, a subordinate
who's not performing well.
But this is all for show.
He wants to show
that in the case of the war going
badly, it's not his fault.
And that he's taking very,
very strong measures
against those
whose fault it is in my assessment
is that'll play pretty well domestically
with with Russians
who believe that to be the case.
They always think
the leader of the country
is sort of above all of this.
And he just needs to lean on his people
a little better.
So I think it's for them
and I think it'll play pretty well.
Jill, do you agree
this is public performance
Oh, there's no question.
And remember,
at the beginning of the war,
he did
basically the same thing
in a shocking event.
When he really excoriated, humiliated
the head of the SVR intelligence, Mr.
Sergei Naryshkin.
He did the very same thing, I mean,
and with a smirk on his face.
So this is as simple as saying
this is classic Putin.
Steve Russia pointed
Putin's chief of general staff
as the military commander
of what they're still calling
a special military operation.
What do you think that is about?
I mean, what's Putin
trying to accomplish with that move?
Is it to have the next fall guy?
Is it
a sign of that
the Russian forces
are going to start to improve?
You know, Kremlinology is
is an opaque science
is that it's really, really hard
to try to figure out
what is in Putin's mind
and that
there's generations of intelligence folks
who have tried to engage
in Kremlinology or Soviet
Soviet theology.
Yeah, it's a hard study
because there's so much going
on, you know, so
start from where Putin sees himself
first and foremost.
The most important thing for Putin
is winning the Ukrainian war.
That's important.
Is it maintaining?
You know, Russia is a great nation
that's important.
But it's all about Vladimir Putin.
It's all about himself
preserving himself
and his style of government.
So what he's trying to do
is he's trying to set people
against each other
to see who the strongest person is.
Of course, if it doesn't go
well, it's going to end up on the new
you know,
the newly appointed
commander who's Gerasimov, who's been
it has been around for quite a while.
So this is no good thing for him.
It's no great assignment
to not be in charge of the Ukrainian war.
But he's also setting himself is setting.
Putin is setting.
You're awesome up against others
in the Kremlin who are vying for power,
guys like Prigozhin, the head of Bognor.
So this is
there's all this politics going on,
some of which has to do with the war.
Much more has to do
with internal Kremlin politics.
Jill,
do you see this
shuffling of responsibility
as a sign of instability?
I think it's a sign of
frustration by the president,
by President Putin,
that the war isn't going well.
I think it's also kind of a power shift.
You know,
Putin's modus operandi for a long time
has been to kind of balance people
who are below him
and they may have
very different viewpoints.
And then look at what
we were just talking about.
His fight between Prigozhin,
a private military contractor, group,
the year group.
And he is in direct verbal
fight with the defense ministry.
He is claiming credit for his guys
taking solider.
And so this this is really extraordinary.
And, you know, Putin has allowed
this type of stuff to happen
and is happening publicly.
But the in the old days,
you would say, well,
he won't let that go on for too long.
But right now, we're not quite sure.
I mean, can
he hold it together
is Prigozhin
really, really getting powerful?
You know,
what's happening to the to the military.
So there are a lot of questions.
I think the deal with
Putin, the Putin's ability
to control the situation.
Jill Dougherty, Steve,
Paul, it's fascinating. I appreciate it.
Thank you.